>> Greg: DID YOU HEAR THE ONE
ABOUT THE PASSENGER YANKED FROM
A SOUTHWEST AIRLINES FLIGHT FOR
MAKING A JOKE?
THE FLIGHT FROM SACRAMENTO TO
AUSTIN, TEXAS, HAD BEEN DELAYED
FOR HOURS WHICH SPURRED FLIGHT
ATTENDANTS TO HAND OUT WATER.
ONE PASSENGER ASKED IF IT WAS
VODKA.
THE YOUNG FLIGHT ATTENDANT
DIDN'T FIND IT FUNNY AND DESPITE
FELLOW PASSENGERS DEFENDING THE
JOKER, THE PLANE WAS TURNED
BACK.
DEPUTIES BOARDED THE VESSEL AND
EXPORTED THE GUY OFF.
AT LEAST HE FOUND A WAY TO GET
OFF THE PLANE IN TIME.
SOUTHWEST SERVES MILLIONS OF
PASSENGERS SO MAYBE THIS
HUMORLESS THIS IS AN EXCEPTION
FOR A COMPANY ONCE KNOWN FOR ITS
IRREVERENCE.
THE INCIDENT IS NO LONGER OUT OF
THE ORDINARY FOR LIFE IN
GENERAL.
FOR SO MANY PEOPLE WHO CAME OF
AGE BUT NEVER GREW UP IN THE ERA
OF SAFE SPACES, JOKES ARE VIEWED
AS ACTUAL OFFENSES.
OFFENSES, AGGRESSIONS.
TRIGGER WARNINGS ARE ENCOURAGED
BEFORE STUDENTS SEE CHALLENGING
PLAYS.
COMEDY SETS ARE STOPPED IF ONE
JOKE HURTS ONE ACTIVISTS
FEELINGS.
GOOD COMEDIANS AVOID COLLEGES
ALTOGETHER.
WE HAVE A GENERATION THAT FAILS
TO SEE HUMOR IS ONE EFFECTIVE
TOOL IN REDUCING TENSION IN
STRESSFUL EVENTS, LIKE A PLANE
STUCK ON A RUNWAY OR STOCK ON
"THE FIVE."
IF HUMANS CAN NO LONGER SEE
HUMOR'S VALUE AND REDUCING
HOSTILITY, WHAT ARE WE LEFT
WITH?
HOSTILITY.
LIFE USED TO BE LIKE THIS.
FUNNY, TRUTHFUL, SHOCKING.
NOW IT'S LIKE THIS.
SCOLDING, SELF SERIOUS,
COMMUNITY AND AS SCHOOLMARM.
IT IS THE SETH MEYERS EFFECT, A
JOKE WAS LIFE BECOMES MUNDANE
AND PALE EVEN LATE AT NIGHT.
YET HE STILL HAS A SHOW.
NOW THAT'S AN UNFUNNY PUNCH LIN
PUNCH LINE.
CAN'T DO JOKES ANYMORE ON THE
PLANE, DANA.
>> Dana: THIS A COUPLE THINGS
THAT YOU CAN'T JOKE ABOUT ON A
PLANE.
BUT EVERYTHING ELSE SHOULD BE
WITHIN THE LIMITS.
THE OTHER THING IS, SOUTHWEST
DOES HAVE PRETTY GREAT STAFF.
THIS SEEMS REALLY WEIRD.
>> Greg: I THINK -- I DON'T
WANT TO BE AGEIST BUT I THINK
IT'S YOUNG PEOPLE.
ALL YOUNG PEOPLE ARE BAD,
SHANNON.
CAN I SAY THAT LEGALLY?
>> Shannon: YES, YOU CAN RIGHT
IT'S YOUR OPINION.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE SHOWS, "THE
OFFICE," YOU COULDN'T MAKE THAT
SHOW NOW.
I JUST FEEL LIKE WHEN I SEE THE
OLD EPISODES.
>> Dana: A LOT OF MENLO MEALS
DO WATCH THAT.
>> Shannon: HOW ARE THEY NOT
PASSED OUT?
>> Greg: EVEN STUFF ON
"FRIENDS" YOU CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT'S HAPPENING.
MAYBE WE ARE BETTER PEOPLE NOW,
MORE ENLIGHTENED, JUAN.
WE ARE SO ENLIGHTENED WE DON'T
NEED JOKES ANYMORE.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW.
I AM A BIG LENNY BRUCE FAN.
I LIKE RICHARD PRYOR, RED FOX.
THEY PUT SOME OF THOSE GUYS IN
JAIL BACK THEN.
I'M NOT SURE WE WERE ALWAYS FULL
OF HUMOR.
THE IDEA THERE WAS TO ABSOLUTELY
PUSH THE LINE, SKEWERED
CONVENTIONAL THINKING IN
AMERICA.
THEY WOULD PUT PEOPLE IN JAIL.
WE DON'T DO THAT.
IT MAKES ME THINK, JESSE
SOMETHING ELSE WAS GOING ON
BETWEEN THE FLIGHT ATTENDANT AND
THAT PERSON.
>> Jesse: DO YOU THINK THEY
HAD A HISTORY?
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW.
>> Greg: I WAS WONDERING ABOUT
THAT.
I FOUND OUT OTHER PEOPLE ON THE
PLANE WERE SHOCKED BY THIS.
I WAS SINGING MAYBE THERE WAS
SOMETHING GOING ON, SOMETHING
ELSE GOING ON.
>> Juan: MAYBE IT WAS HIS TONE
OR MAYBE HE HAD SPILLED
SOMETHING ON HER FOOT.
>> Jesse: TONE IS IMPORTANT
AND I WOULD HAVE TO DISAGREE
WITH YOU ABOUT LOCKING PEOPLE UP
FOR TELLING JOKES.
TRUMP JOKED THAT RUSSIA, IF
YOU'RE LISTENING, HILLARY'S
EMAILS.
THAT WAS IN THE MUELLER REPORT
AS A POTENTIAL OBSTRUCTION
CHARGE.
THAT'S HOW SERIOUSLY THEY TOOK
HIS JOKE.
>> Greg: I SEE IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: COME ON.
>> Juan: ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
INVESTIGATORS COME OUT.
TAKE IT AS A JOKE.
>> Greg: HERE IS THE BIG
PROBLEM.
YOU HAVE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH JOKES.
IF IT'S NOT FUNNY TO THEM, THEN
IT'S OFFENSIVE AND THAT'S THE
TOOL THAT KEEPS SOCIETY GOING.
IT'S A LUBRICATION.
IF YOU ARE IN A MEETING AND YOU
NEED -- LET'S SAY A MEETING
BETWEEN TRIBES.
I'M SURE HUMOR WAS THE TOOL THAT
KEPT YOU FROM KILLING EACH
OTHER.
AND THAT'S WHAT SCARES ME.
>> Juan: IS THIS EVEN A BAD
JOKE?
IT WASN'T OFFENSIVE.
>> Greg: WAITING HERE FOR A
COUPLE HOURS, LET'S HOPE IT'S
VODKA.
>> Juan: HOW IS THAT
OFFENSIVE?
>> Shannon: SHE SAID I DON'T
FIND THAT FUNNY.
>> Dana: OKAY, FINE.
YOU TELL THEM TO TURN AROUND THE
PLANE AND YOU RUIN EVERYBODY
ELSE'S DAY?
>> Shannon: MAYBE IT'S TRUE
THAT WE THINK OUR JOKES THAT ARE
HILARIOUS AND WONDERFUL, WE ARE
GETTING OLD.
I MADE A JOKE ABOUT CARMEN
MIRANDA YESTERDAY.
EVERYONE WAS LOOKING AT ME.
NO ONE KNOWS WHO IT IS.
>> Greg: SHE WAS A FLAMENCO
DANCER.
>> Jesse: I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> Jesse: WHO?
CARMEN SANDIEGO?
>> Juan: YOU KNEW WHEN TRUMP
TOLD THE JOKE.
>> Jesse: "MAD" MAGAZINE.
>> Greg: IT'S THE FACT THAT WE
ARE RAISING, WE ARE RAISING
CHILDREN IN THEIR SAFE CAGES SO
IF THEY GO OUTSIDE, SOMETHING --
>> Jesse: IT WASN'T JUST THAT
SHE DIDN'T LIKE THE JOKE.
SHE ABUSED HER POWER AND KICKED
HIM OFF.
>> Dana: THAT'S THE OTHER
THING.
>> Greg: I HOPE WE DON'T FIND
OUT MORE ABOUT THE STORY AND IT
TURNS OUT TO BECOME TIGHTLY
WRONG.
I REALLY DON'T WANT TO DO A
CORRECTION.
>> Jesse: I HANDLE THE
CORRECTIONS.
>> Greg: ASKED, JESSE DOES ALL